Yeah,
yeah.
Yup.
So you just find whatever's laying around tire cinder.
Anything,
you know,
if I have a wall,
I could do a lot with that.
Let's say it's a five,
six foot wall.
There's a lot you could do it that lot you could do with just a tree.
Um,
some cinder blocks,
you know,
uh,
and then every once in a while guys will bring like a 90 pound sandbag or a
couple of kettle bells because now it's a thing,
right?
Expect it sort of like,
hi,
we want to do a pat Mac workout after range day.
And uh,
you know,
Kudos to those guys because that shit that's hard.
You know,
when you're on the range all day working your ass off and especially in a
blazing hot sun and guys hang out to do a workout with me,
like bad kudos
to you bro.
Well,
one of the cool things about the internet is that people find other people that
want to push themselves and they find inspiration through guys like you.
And there's,
you know,
dozens of guys like you online that are like fun to follow and you get,
you go,
this guy guy's doing it.
I got to fucking get off my ass and go do it.
Because sometimes people just need an example.
They need someone to look at and go this and it literally can change the way you
live your life.
No doubt.
See a guy who's doing what you're doing.
You like,
God dammit,
he's fucking intense all the time he's getting after it.
Look at his beard
like lucky over here there's a cinder block.
I love that.
Eagle Lake,
Texas.
Probably three years ago.
What's the smoke?
Is that exhaust fume or gunshot?
No,
the the owner.
I know what that he was,
he was smoking.
Um,
it was a smoker.
Oh,
he was making meat.
Oh Nice.
Yup,
Yup.
Yeah.
But those are,
that's,
those are hard workouts,
man swings in between the legs like that.
That's how you build the,
the real core strength.
If you're back and you know,
your,
your whole,
the whole spinal column.
Yeah.
Keep it tight and strong.
No,
it's,
it's funny you get,
even today I read,
I'm reading some comments about whatever it is.
There's a lot of stupid people out there when it comes to like not understanding
the right way to work out,
right?
And I want to tell these guys,
hey man,
two things.
One is if you do,
if you do what you've always done,
you're going to get what you've always gotten.
Number two,
I didn't go home last night and smoke a bunch of crack and dream of shit up.
I mean,
there's not,
I've,
I've done a law to freaking research a lot of,
um,
there's a lot of time and effort that's gone into this and um,
they'll say,
hey man,
you're gonna throw your back out doing that stuff.
No mother Fucker,
that's,
that's in your back.
You know,
work in that transverse plane is what guys neglect a lot.
See here,
here we go.
I'm going to get on this freaking soap box.
I swear to God,
go ahead and go get on the bum.
Do a box where most guys,
most guys work out,
they live in what I call a sagittal listic environment.
You know,
three planes of motion,
frontal saggital transverse.
So they're in this sagittal world doing bench and concentration curls.
Um,
out of the three planes of motion,
I would say that transverse is most important.
Additionally,
when we work out,
I would also argue with confidence that it's the plain emotion that is most
neglected.
That transverse plane.
I like to tell guys that in the transverse plane lives lifesaving an ass kicking
their full reasons why we should,
why we should exercise.
This is Max opinion.
Okay.
One self preservation,
longevity,
good for your health.
Stronger,
longer motion is lotion.
Number two,
the ability to save your own life.
Having that confidence,
no one.
Yup.
I could pull myself out of that burning coal or over that wall or whatever.
Number three,
more importantly to me is being Batman,
the ability to save somebody else's life.
So that's three reasons.
The last one,
kicking somebody fucking ass.
So when I look at workout,
I look at those four things,
right?
They're not like cosmetics or anything.
Cosmetics is a cool byproducts.
Do you work out right?
You're going to look better.
You look better,
you feel better,
you're more confident,
you're more confident.
It performed better cause confidence,
performance work hand in hand.
Sure.
So I mean there's no freaking magic elixir to it.
You know it and it's,
and it's hard
like to see,
there was like,
if you do bench press,
you see a chest puff up and they see those results.
I always tell people,
if there's one exercise I would recommend,
like people who do Jujitsu,
Turkish getup,
right?
It's the least romance week.
It's the least romantic of all workouts.
Nobody wants to do those goddamn things.
Go to go to a gym.
You could go to a hundred gyms if you're lucky.
You find one person doing Turkish getup.
Yep.
Every gym we'll have someone,
someone somewhere is doing bench press and someone's doing curls and lat pull
down machine and all that normal shit.
Yeah.
Working out
[inaudible] there.
It's,
it's like an anachronism.
You know,
they're working in a world like a muscle and fitness world still,
and that's fine working in isolation if that's your job.
There's three people who,
three types of people who should work,
how it concentration,
like doing uh,
a curl or some,
you know,
a concentration curls,
a professional bodybuilder,
right.
That's your job man at your sport.
Number two,
you recovering from surgery and atrophy.
So it's physical therapy.
Number three,
he had no fucking idea what you're doing or you're a model and trying to look
sexy as fuck.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah.
Right.
So they fall in that same category trying to like print out.
Yup.
Yeah.
If you,
it's,
it's just not what you really need to exercise with.
Exercise is something that's going to mimic what you would actually do in real
life.
Picking up things,
moving them around like farmer walks.
Yup.
Pharma Walk,
very unglamorous.
Carry a heavy ass bell in one hand and just walk around for like a half a mile
and be your fucking forum would be dying.
Your legs would be killing you.
Your core is going to be shaking.
It's amazing.
And I liked the way you put it to carry on once,
you know,
one side of it.
Yeah,
that's,
you got to do it.
People don't know that.
They try to do with two arms,
but with two arms it bounces out and then it's really just a grip and a leg
exercise,
a little bit of lats and traps.
But really why you want to do is one,
100 pounder on one hand,
carry that bitch.
Everything is just kind of balance it out and then turn around,
put it on the left hand.
Yeah.
It's great.
We do 'em at my gym,
a lot of that where we load one side of the time.
One of the things I love to hear is a guy will say,
man,
I'd never see you doing the same thing.
Yeah.
I'm like,
well,
I pretty much don't.
Um,
because I don't want to fall into a Rut of complacent adaptation,
you know?
Um,
so even guys who say,
do you,
uh,
do you do like Oly Lifts?
Yeah,
of course.
Every once in a while I'll probably do a dead lift,
a standard dead lift once every two months,
but I'm doing variations of that.
Like a shovel dead lift or a suitcase,
you know,
dead lifts that suck and are like you said,
are not glamorous.
Yeah.
Um,
I'll throw those in a bunch.
Uh,
but do you do much cardio?
Here's how I knock out cardio is uh,
have a uh,
formula.
Um,
with this I have a program combat strength train.
I got an e book and website and all of this.
And those are your programs,
something that people could sign up for?
Yeah,
yeah,
they can buy the ebook.
Is it,
what's the website for Jamie could pull it up.
Combat Strength training.com.
And the formula is work in work in anaerobic chunks in circuit to near metabolic
threshold to meet in a robot goal and then like 30,
35 minutes.
So that doesn't include warm up,
you know,
so you good.
Whatever it is.
For me it's like bag work or something for warm up,
just to make sure everything's Loosey Goosey.
The older you are,
the more you have to warm up,
man.
Damn.
Don't Jack yourself up.
It's called fitness,
not brokeness.
Yeah.
People.
That's another thing that people don't like to do because it's not glamorous and
because the people get lazy,
they don't want to do that workout where the preworkout,
they don't want to do all the skipping rope and all.
They'll just switch and stances and jumping jacks and all that stuff.
But you really need to break a sweat of real sweat before you actually start
lifting weights.
And then even if you lift weights or do anything,
like say if you're going to do get kettlebells,
I'll start off with 35 pounds.
I'll do everything nice and light at first.
They don't,
I don't start off heavy.
No.